[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what is
making the headlines with the columnist
broadcaster steve richards and the
former government special adviser salma
shah lovely to see both of you
so as ever we turn our attention to
those front pages the metro carries
claims from the conservative mp william
rag that tory whips have been known to
threaten mps to withhold funding from
their constituencies if they don't
support the prime minister
the guardian has the headline tory's
using dirty tactics to get mps to back
johnson
the i described the intra party turmoil
as a tory civil war over boris johnson's
future
the star has sent a journalist in a duck
costume
to downey street suggesting the prime
minister might be a lame one
the telegraph is that some schools are
still telling pupils they need to wear
masks contradicting the government's
instruction that they can stop as of
today
the mail says the prime minister is
facing a battle with unions who are
resisting his efforts to get workers to
return to their offices
in the express the chancellor is said to
be considering a plan to offer 500 pound
payouts to help people with their energy
bills
and the financial times reporting that
the ukrainian president has taken
offense after joe biden suggested the us
wouldn't get involved if russian
movement into ukraine turned out to be a
minor incursion
well a quick reminder before we hear
from our guests but by scanning the qr
code you will you'll see on your screen
during the program uh you can check out
the front pages of tomorrow's newspapers
while you watch
so
let's speak then to steve richards and
sal shah great to see both of you salma
what is going on is this all normal or
is something really going wrong in the
work of the whips
well it's it's actually not normal and
it's it's definitely not normal to
expose the work of the whips they're
supposed to be in the shadows usually
sort of whispering into people's ears
and um ensuring that you know discipline
and order is maintained um i think
what's interesting about this is that we
saw this reprieve um for the most part
of today granted to the prime minister
after the defection and david davis's
intervention yesterday
but then you had william ragg give a
statement at the at the beginning of his
committee session of which he's chair
the public administration committee in
the commons um
laying out very clearly that uh whips
have been behaving inappropriately or
pressure has been applied from the whips
office um for two reasons one uh
suggesting that um uh
mps have been told that they can't have
certain things in their constituencies
if they don't um if they continue to
pursue a vote of no confidence and also
allegations that their whips office or
it's certainly uh the operation have
been uh briefing against uh mps so some
very very serious accusations um and
giving uh this story new momentum uh
through william rags um comments and
also being endorsed by uh
our defecting mp uh chris from very
south um saying that he had actually
experienced this firsthand so
very unusual uh very uh explosive and
pretty serious allegations and looking
like it could get even more explosive
just got the times in steve uh torrey
rebels retaliate they say that tory mps
who want to oust boris johnson are
considering publishing a secretly
recorded conversation with the chief
whip and text messages after they accuse
the government of blackmail and
intimidation they say the rebels met
today to discuss how to respond they
were comparing notes and discussing
whether or not to make public texts and
other evidence they had from the webs
one member has recorded a heated
conversation that they had with the
chief whip i mean they're going great
guns this this blue on blue is full
scale now
yeah and one of the common features of
this particular saga is evidence
surfacing
you know you have claims and counter
claims but then evidence comes up and
notches up or ratchets up the political
temperature considerably so that will be
an interesting
development it is
part of what is inevitably a seismic
phase in british politics some tory mps
are contemplating removing a prime
minister it doesn't get bigger
and some of johnson's allies are working
overtime to try and prop him up
and when you get that dynamic you're
going to get stories like this
and because there is this now gap
between all the stuff that's erupted in
recent days and awaiting this much
sighted uh report
on the parties uh there's going to be
more of this and it is inevitable
when the stakes are so high say the
removal of a prime minister now johnson
level is relevant to tonight and what
we're here for
he's got some of his newspapers holding
back a bit um if this were a labour
prime minister i can tell you the mail
the telegraph and others would be going
crazy on the front pages they're not
tonight but it is still
a huge moment in british politics and no
one's quite sure which way it's going to
go
and in terms of the language being used
on the front pages if we look at the
metro which you know uses the word
blackmail and on the front page of the
guardian dirty tactics it sounds worse
than the parties whether or not it
resonates as much with members of the
pal uh the public's helmer is is another
matter um but steve used the word this
is seismic that people are watching how
to have an 80-seat major majority and
implode aren't they
yes i think that's true but i think that
there is there are always huge uh
pitfalls no matter how uh strong the
majority might be for a prime minister
the question here is about the fact that
uh a lot of this feels self-inflicted by
the prime minister the only thing that i
would say about the sort of headlines of
blackmail and dirty tactics this is
clearly something that has been um
said by those people accusing number 10
in the whips office of behaving in this
way and i do have some sympathy for the
line that's coming out that's saying
that we actually need to see some
evidence of this because
you cannot stop people from building
schools and hospitals in certain areas
just because they've decided to go
against a certain vote whether that's
been threatened um or not is certainly
the question but i've never seen a
process that would make that possible
because actually it goes through the
department it goes through rigorous
checks and then once you've sort of done
planning and you know talk to local
authorities and lots of other
stakeholders about these things that is
the process by which new schools and
hospitals are put into local
constituencies so it's more than just
this kind of centralized control so it
would be interesting to see
if there is a distinction between people
suggesting this and the reality of that
actually happening because that that
seems incongruous to me
do you i mean do you see this um as a
concerted plot um and in fact in a sense
you know is everybody being played here
you know it's a defector to labor via a
committee chair one of the first to put
their letter in wanting boris johnson to
go backed by another person who's put
their letter in andrew bridgen um and
we're all jumping on it i mean
you know do you have some sympathy with
the with the pm and the downing street
team over this one steve
no um but i don't think it's um what
we're seeing here sophisticated
coordinated uh plot no doubt people are
talking all the time
and how to mount pressure those who want
to get rid of him how to mount pressure
and those who want to keep him how to
keep him
but it elevates them all too much to
hail coordinated plots i think there's a
degree of chaos which is part of the
ingredient to this on both sides
remember the new intake of the 2019
election
are relatively new to politics and this
is politics as i said at the beginning
on it doesn't get bigger an attempt to
remove a prime minister and they are
changing their minds sometimes yes we're
going to do it no we're not going to do
it so i think it's um let's say
elevating it all too much to imply
levels of coordinated sophistication but
they are talking and they are trying to
work out what move to make next but i
kind of think this is a symptom
of the wider malaise at the top not
bigger than you know the kind of black
male allegations and so on um the crisis
revolves around leadership and whether
they should make a move against someone
who remember is being accused of not
only breaking his own rules but lying
about it now he denies that he's got
people trying to keep him in place but
those tory mps have decided those two
leaps are leaps too far
up we know the final number but clearly
there are a significant number who've
reached that conclusion
the i uh if we look at that tory's civil
war they call it a cabinet minister
has said johnson faces death by a
thousand cuts as it's always unlikely
you shoot and take him out in one round
the mirror is just in as well are also
going on with the blackmail story the
lowest of the low uh christian
wakefield's allegations there and then
finally the daily star selma is johnson
lame dark i mean this is a bit of fun
from them but actually it goes back to
the question that beth asked him earlier
this week
you might survive but can you recover
and ultimately that might end up being
the the most important question
look i think that is the most important
question because as i as i've been
reminding people um you know steve will
know this too but having been in the
center of government when uh theresa may
faced her uh leadership challenge one
can see um the the sort of context in
which actually it just saps your
authority away from you and that is
certainly a danger for boris johnson
that he like theresa may if there is a
no confidence vote actually survives it
um but loses all kinds of authority and
has a cabinet that sort of behaves very
badly around him or a parliamentary
party that stops listening and sort of
rebels on other issues that aren't
directly linked to their number 10
parties um or or anything specifically
to do with this episode
so there will there will be some um
attention on that there's obviously the
issue of what happens at the local
elections and whether there's going to
be losses that are linked back to this
as well um so there's a lot to consider
and mps are also going to ask themselves
which is why
we've seen in some reporting you know
about new chiefs of staff and clearing
out advisors and these are going to ask
themselves whether the prime minister
can get back on the front foot in a
credible way and show some grip of the
government
okay uh can be a busy week next week by
the sounds of it if indeed sue gray's
report is then published but we've got
lots more to talk about the big policy
announcements of this week have been of
course from kobed some schools are
pushing back against the government and
telling pupils to keep wearing masks we
will discuss that in the telegraph
that's next
[Music]
[Music]
you're watching the press preview are
with me now steve richards and sam
michelle welcome back to both of you um
so fairly swiftly uh some of the covered
restrictions have been lifted schools
already in england not mandated to wear
masks and the daily telegraph said that
some schools are defying the prime
minister over this steve
fair enough i mean once again it's uh
the phrase is personal responsibility or
in terms of workplaces the head teachers
responsibility or whatever um absolutely
fair enough um it's his decision boris
johnson's it is connected with though
not holy but connected with his
political
uh turmoil and the need to try and woo
his mps have always loathed these
restrictions i think it is
understandable and commendable that some
headteachers will make their own
judgment on this um
we don't know for sure that we're out of
this at all
even though the figures are looking good
so yeah the um
yeah they've got every right to do it
and a right to do it yes relatively good
i suppose with 107 000 cases today it's
it is all relative if you look back to
the date of delta um but the daily
mail's picked up on this idea of the
return as well and this is uh wanting
civil servants to set an example the
suggestion in the mail that unions will
have none of it selma
yes and this is an interesting story
because again it is that question about
personal responsibility but if you are
mandated at work uh then how does that
how does that actually play out um but
people are very very worried about urban
centers and what that's doing to offices
and what that's doing to work culture
and work environment and indeed what
it's doing for productivity so i can see
it certainly from both sides
so you know the manager class who want
to get people back for want of a better
phrase and those people who are either
struggling because they are worried
about their personal risk and they still
think that actually um the uh covert is
still um
going to be a worry for them uh but also
people who think that the flexible
working uh works better and want to sort
of keep a hold of that so there's going
to be that conflict i think uh for some
time yet um i think with the males which
are thinking about how the civil service
should set the example that is
interesting because the civil service
does try to sort of borrow from what's
happening in corporate britain
and so i think they probably will be
trying to pursue flexible working which
will no doubt outrage the mail and
probably ministers as well yeah salma
sama shah steve richards lovely to have
you both on thank you both very much
indeed